[Music]
on three big breath in one
2 Waverly hi Auntie what are you doing
here I haven't had time off since med
school so now is my chance before I
started my
residency I haven't told my
[Music]
parents good
hi you're Rachel's neighbor I'm I'm
Blake nice to meet
[Music]
you she
okay are you okay I'm okay are you okay
me morning hi you can't swim huh I kind
of miss that as a kid I could teach
you why are you doing this like spending
time with you I hate thinking about all
the years I SP without knowing you and
weird tell me about your parents I've
been doing them 4 years they make sure I
have everything that I need but they
don't really know
me are you looking at me
no I kind of have feelings for Blake no
kidding here you are having the best
summer of your life going after a boy
you like I think I see love BS she's
thinking about moving here it's too soon
rain
hi Mom Dr Wong squeeze you into his
research team this is a for your future
my parents want me in Toronto I'm not
normally very
impulsive where can we just stay in that
[Music]
moment B you lied to us I want to stay
here with you but I do want to be a
doctor I don't have to act like this is
anything more than
summerling it's time you ask yourself
what you want to do I don't want this
summer to end you have to make yourself
known in this life not for anyone
else but for
[Music]
you